be on today's show I get some breaking
news for you dude it's gonna blow your
mind no no UFOs nope they found
something in the water no dude no oh
there's something in the water that's
CNN and fox what happened this just hit
the news it's fresh off the press and
it's for you buddy okay Tucker Carlson
fired from Fox Don Lemon fired from CNN
Don Lemon
fired of mainstream media
see ya Walking Papers tell me more
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
uh Brandon just fell asleep because I
started talking about how beautiful
Oregon is and no [__] yeah of course
it's beautiful the most beautiful State
waterfalls oh Mossy covered Cliffs oh
trees as far as the eye can see herds of
elk and Portland of the free home of wow
Portland has its challenges and when you
when you drive in well it's got some
City when Bane took over I stayed in an
amazing hotel called The Nines though
sure great Hotel watch all art and I did
have a ridiculously good time now ask me
why I'm sore my legs my biceps my back
is CrossFit sore go ahead and ask me why
why are your legs and back sorry about
an hour outside of Portland
I I I caught myself
two count them two eight foot plus
sturgeons eight foot monsters in the
Deep yeah what'd you guys use the first
one so so
I didn't know what to expect we got on
the boat and um it's called broken back
fishing like broken back sturgeon
fishing break your back fishing the guy
our guide our the guy who owns it
Charles uh black belt and Jiu Jitsu
cauliflower ears like oh what do you do
just an older guy he's like ah you know
blah blah anyway because I teach people
how to fish dumbass we get on and uh I
don't know what to expect but he takes a
hook about his little like Yay big like
bigger than like a real hook like a real
hook a little thicker one yeah pulls out
a fish that if I caught if I caught it
I'd be like that's a fish remember the
fish we were catching no Bubba oh that's
adorable oh it's like true a straight up
trout you would eat oh a trout you would
serve to like oh like at a nice
restaurant yes but a trout you'd serve
to two people oh wow right they well and
he was alive yeah so I go I go what's
with that no no he wasn't alive Frozen
oh but I go what's with that trailer it
was called a Shad they call it a Shad
some kind of a fish
and then he he hooks it and wraps the
line around it but the line's super
thick so I'm like what the what are we
catching here
well
well they're sharks
well they're sharks I literally he
throws it out there were you in the
ocean no we're in a no sir we're on in
the Columbia River sir in the Columbia
River right right what sharks well they
look like sharks sir oh there you go
okay right there you go with no touch or
p's and q's okay don't tell me the
Sharks in Portland Oregon remember the
catfish family
but um I
yeah you got to see how big they are
it's it's it's ridiculous that there you
go
and that's what I pulled out of the
water that's not Photoshop could you
have brought one back for my tank dude
you know what you know what juvenile
I they breach the water you'll see them
kick out of the water that big and it's
like what in the world so the the
getting them getting when they hook on
and you're pulling to fight three rounds
I woke up my legs my legs literally are
still sore I'm like it's a full body to
ring them in right because you have to
be uh seat belted in to the boat no
because they're not doing that you just
pull you give it line you pull you give
it line but it was this that yeah it's
not like you're catching a marlin where
you're you're talking about hours and
you'll be strapped and you also have it
like you have the Rope on it I mean you
can't oh this you could you didn't have
to put you put you wedge it here between
my legs my taint is sore yeah my taint
hurts but and you're out there for how
long you got two big boys 25 minutes
rope the first one in which was they
think probably weighed about 450 pounds
you guys kill and eat it nope you you
grab it you put your hands in his mouth
you pull it up you take some pics you
keep it skills in the water that's the
rule yeah or you can you can take them
over to the sand bank and do that with
them with waiters which we did so you
guys catch them and let them go yeah
okay
they think roughly 60 years old
you know what you know we call We call
we caught an eight and a half footer now
they had caught he had caught a
13-footer let me say it again
that's well over 100 years old well it's
so big because they lived so long they
live forever and they just live on the
bottom of the lake and they see a better
picture of one chin why are they they're
cool yeah they're really cool it's like
you know how like at least they don't
eat those but like Bluefin Tunas
Everybody Eats in their uh pokeballs you
ever seen a bluefin tuna they're
beautiful they're so cool look at that
and when you see them like they they
it's friendly yeah they are like when
they come what they look like it looks
like avatar dragons let you fly yes but
not mean in the water like gay Avatar
Dragon yes yeah just in the water they
scare you in the water when you see
their back they were like dinosaurs yeah
literally dinosaurs man those are teeth
they look like that it I recommend it
highly if you go out there it's just fun
it's a complete workout and it's you're
just on the Columbia area you're out for
a Halloween cut too you know what we
caught two in like an hour the whole
thing took an hour an hour I'm good you
know what you guys want to do me too 6
a.m to noon it's like no no no hey no no
six hours I'm not another way one hour
after I see the water catch the fish so
so you see that on camera they were
making fun of me for that because after
the first one I was like I'm good and
the camera guy was shooting for best
stuff he goes
um I need a different angle and I'm like
do we though and I go look and I I
literally said this I go uh so we catch
it 25 minutes throw another one in it's
15 minutes and Daddy's ADHD and patience
has run out now seen it bored seen it
yeah me too seen it I'm the same trees
beautiful waterfall beautiful amazing
Oregon I saw the sturgeon a lot of them
in here damn
okay now I go I go I'm gonna give it
five more minutes I say that boom
and then yeah it's longer than that yeah
I'm just that's how I was when we were
fishing in the ocean for the babies
that's how their mouths are they got a
lot of suckers yeah oh little vacuums on
the bottom yeah they vacuum up the
ground they're cool man they are really
cool
there's not a you can't there's no tank
you'd house them in unless you're
Shaquille O'Neal like you have to have
well you can have a baby one you got a
baby one yeah but that baby I would bet
they grow like arowanas they grow at
least an inch to two every month yeah
see how much they grow because this one
was 60 years old and how fast they grow
60. also I don't want that fish for 60
years right
how's the 20-foot sturgeon look at that
for a second let me see that 30 inches
in about seven years
that's manageable no it's not no how
many inches two feet two two feet uh two
feet six inches well if you do right
not bad but dude it would be a nightmare
you'd have to put them in a river by the
time it gets old like the amount of
money for that take you that I don't
know it says thank you Anita
I can't 5 000 gallon tank he caught he
caught this 13-foot thing and the head
was that big so yeah you need a big
yeah someone has fish tanks no no no in
aquariums like in Long Beach yeah I
think you should get one unless you're
Dennis Rodman you're not putting that in
your living room they also they're if
you can do a big fish you want something
dangerous you don't want that stupid
thing like yeah
they just suck the floor yeah look at
the baby
they are cool looking oh come on dude
get a couple Sturgis a little Sturgis
yeah
it's a sturgeon stock oh he is cute yeah
they have like the alligator tails
though yeah now you saw my boy chill Sun
two out there chill sun and came to the
Saturday show connected YouTube to come
with this Dime Piece wife brought his
amazing wife look at how look at how
chill's leaning forward that I was like
chill I sent him a text I go can you not
lean forward like that like are you
about to do the dosey doe I don't know
what it was he's trying to make himself
smaller around me because he's every bit
of 240. I mean his head is huge I mean
him do the same thing I I I I bend down
yes but he's not as tall as you he's
just uh yeah look at Kevin how big Kevin
is like Kevin's a big man he's a big man
um great hair compared does Kevin have
better hair than I do now um but chill
chill uh chill in his classes
the best he brought his father-in-law
he's brought his dying peace wife and he
brought she she uh was with her parents
and his father-in-law is a an old school
Cowboy from Oregon yeah handlebar what
mustache in great shape white mustache
cowboy hat like scarf like a cowboy
looks like a character from 18th what
works in there it works in the back
country yeah keep going
no there's a difference I'm just we're
vibing he's a man of the West he's a man
of the West yeah you know white
supremacy started up there right well do
you know the history I'm not going to
talk about that look at challenge it's
just U.S history the jail at 180. look
at him there yeah oh so depleted so
depleted dude that's a huge huge cut for
him because you're talking about a guy
with a head that you and I could we
could live in
it's got a big old one of the best man
absolutely love chill the best the best
well he was I was thinking about it as
far as like one of the most mainstream
characters in UFC he's massive massive
like Mass everybody was talking about
him good or bad so that was his game
plan like Colby does it now to the
extreme but at the time jail was
tasteful yeah yeah amazing you got the
Brazilians and Silva funny he was funny
he just had Jon Jones constantly chasing
Jon Jones amazing even though you know
the awful fights for him he even said
what was great about him also was he
goes you and I did a podcast with him
and he said I said was
how strong was John he goes Brian he was
so strong the minute he grabbed me I
wanted to get the hell out of the
Octagon he was the only fight I've ever
like started and got I'm not gonna win
this fight yeah he told me that was the
only thing he was like I'm probably not
gonna win this one yeah no [__] and he's
you know he's a naturally one he's not a
20 Fiverr no he's 85 all day oh he's an
85 all day he's not two or five okay but
he's tiny he has no problem putting he
has more now no no no no when he's
fighting he's yeah you're trying to kill
a lot for a long time not a 205 okay so
now you see him now because he's older
but yeah when he's fighting 85 year old
day yeah so he was about he walked
around at 205 or something yeah maybe
yeah 210 Max Max he's a complete 185
yeah makes sense great guy though
the best the best intelligent and just
you know yeah one of the best we have
yep hey B let's take a little break from
chatting about the world because the NBA
playoffs are the only thing that matter
right now dude and you make bank with my
friends at DraftKings Sportsbook and
official sports playing part of the NBA
get in on excitement of every game with
a touch of a button new customers can
make a five dollar pregame money line
bet and score 150 in bonus bets if your
team wins plus everyone can score a no
sweat same game parlay every day during
the NBA Playoffs open the DraftKings
sportswear app opt-in and plays the same
game parlay on any NBA game if it
doesn't hit you'll get a bonus bet back
up to ten dollars ten dollars my nuggets
are up three to one they're gonna seal
it tomorrow so don't definitely bet on
them yet the Lakers they're gonna do the
damn thing against Memphis you got the
Knicks rolling you also got Golden State
they're definitely one at home on the
road I don't know but the push to game
six at least download the app right now
you sign up uh with the code fighter new
customers can make a five dollar pregame
moneyline bet score 150 in bonus bets if
your team wins only at DraftKings
Sportsbook with the code fighter gaming
problem called winner Gambler in
Massachusetts call it 800-37-5050 or
gambling or visit gambling
helpline.org in New York call 8778 Hope
NY or text Hope NY 467-369
uh in Kansas call 800-522 4700 on behalf
of Boot Hill Casino and Resort 21 plus
in most eligible States but age varies
by jurisdiction eligibility restrictions
apply see draftkings.com Sportsbook for
details and state specific responsible
gambling resources
see show notes for details DraftKings
promo code fighter and B you love nuts
dude I just I just ate I just ate a
Macadamia a white chocolate uh macadamia
nut bar you must be so rich because
macadamia nuts are so uh for the one
percent well the best they're the most
expensive and best nuts available there
are the delicacy they are the nut of
nuts due to the lowest carb of any
popular nut 33 less than almonds and 50
less than cashews they have the best fat
profile of any nut like avocados on
steroids okay they have more
monosaturated fat that's a fat known for
the ultra healthy Mediterranean diet
okay
they have more monosaturated fat than
olive oil do you tell me all this stuff
but these macadamia nuts are so
expensive and they're so hard to find
where can I find them at uh well it's
called House of macadamia let me explain
this to you they they work vertically
with 90 Farmers okay to make the highest
quality macadamia nuts in the world all
right it's a coalition of South African
farmers and they invest in bringing this
incredible superfood and it is a
superfood to you house of macadamias has
an amazing range of products no added
sugar artificial ingredients from from
hand sorted nuts they sort them by hand
bro dude dude if you give me a cold
pressed extra virgin Macadamia Oil I'm
gonna bust how about I pull that come
with your body and rub that in your
skin and then you run a chocolate
macadamia nuts how about I dry the
macadamia nut oil off in that thick head
of hair guess what though it'll stay on
my hands that's how beautiful and
luxurious it is yeah by the way but this
house of macadamas have some sort of
special offer if we use the code tfak
for 20 off your order and they're giving
you a free bottle of cold press extra
virgin Macadamia Oil worth 20 buckaroos
if you visit
houseofmacademias.com tfak you know why
you should use extraversion macadamia
nut oil over uh I don't know coconut oil
and olive oil the Nokes Foundation did a
study on macadamia nut oil and it
outperformed both coconut and olive oil
and its beneficial effects on overall
humans okay more questions yeah say less
I'm in we're going to go to the house of
macadamias.com
tfak get the nuts in your mouth get your
nuts
and then I I chopped two trees down I
chopped two 80 year old trees down with
a chance have you ever done that no
interesting it's interesting because you
did take a while because you had a
chainsaw so so this was kind of an
education for me because we go we want
to go with the axe men you know they
said there's a TV show called The ax-men
so you go and work with these
lumberjacks and um this guy named Mike
Beal who is an old school Lumberjack 61
years old giant Vikings wrist this big
and uh
we he fires it up and he goes so a
little dangerous here because you never
know which way it's going to fall yeah
you gotta move so I'm gonna wedge it
there's a way but when I say run you run
but you don't run you run to the side so
it's going on correct you want to run
that way but I don't know
you don't know I don't speak tree no he
cuts the first tree down to show us with
a chainsaw and Technology sir you've
internet around 80 years you're you're
this thick that's cool it's you
if you know how to do it
that's it it's a big fig tree a huge
thing I was like oh no now why are you
guys ruining trees no well because
that's an area that's that you harvest
because those trees have reached
maturity they stop growing and and some
of them are dead they're already dead
okay so you you then you it's Douglas
fur which is a super hard wood that you
use for like main frames and stuff like
that but um I chopped down I'm chopping
it down he goes okay run run and I go
that's wrong yeah and I I was going to
leave the chainsaw there and he goes
grab the chainsaws yeah but the sound is
wild so did that and then
made some boots
standard Boot factory
walked home with four daddy stays busy
out there huh Daddy's just looking for
content and uh looking for Content shot
some content didn't Shoot Portland
proper because well they still have a go
in the coffee shop there once you
interview some of the homeless out there
still have a they still have a zombie
problem yes they still have a zombie
problem now the mayor is trying he's
been there since 2017 how's Portland
been boom he's doing a great job um they
call them unhoused Camp you're unhoused
campers
remember Freddie can't say homeless nope
we've heard of them as and we don't say
substance abuse we say substance use
okay and mental health challenges or
actually they say mental health
um something like mental health episodes
see the left is very good at changing
the wording yeah and also make sure you
don't decriminalize criminals like
criminals Portland's a disaster but the
outskirts like where you were out it's
great unbelievable yeah and that's where
the real people are real people aren't
important yeah like if you talk to
people about your show none of them like
we don't even come to the city in years
man right yeah no one lives there some
parts of Portland though are like it's
getting better because what they're
doing is they're building encampments
they're going to put they're going to
take everybody no more camping there's a
camping ban now in Portland finally and
they're going to take them all and put
them in these massive 10 cups yeah
they're all going to want to go there
yeah well so so now you're gonna have to
because they'll give you a citation if
you don't then you'll have to go we'll
see we'll see yeah we'll see but it's
really interesting because that's
because it's gotten too untenable it's
gotten ridiculous yeah and like anything
else the pendulum will swing back but
white people who don't have never
suffered like white people when they get
too comfortable get weird well that in
no sun either you need Vitamin D I think
[__] with people's heads oh yeah you go
crazy now don't get me wrong my fans
they come to play and they are they're
no-nonsense people they're just like we
agree but there's a there's a contingent
of far left weird white people up there
for sure like the weird if you ever want
to know the whitest the most liberal
crazy white white people go to college
go to those yeah yeah now they make a
main cappuccino well correct me and I
don't want to call them by the right
pronoun well I'm gonna I'm gonna get
your take on this if you don't mind I'm
not sharing that story bring it up nice
try I'm gonna bring it up nope not sure
would you say though that in Portland
there are a lot of people who are men
who decide that they are trans but put
zero effort into it so they have a beard
but they put on they put on a dress you
gotta earn those pronouns dude a little
bit okay let me call you Mary can I get
a little work a little effort could you
shave your back anything right I have
hairy shoulders and be called to her I
mean you know what I'm saying yeah can
you put a lip gloss on in uh in a dress
you haven't earned it I mean sir I need
more effort sir yeah you gotta earn it
you're you're are you messing with me
yeah that I go uh I'll have some coffee
bro
bro yeah they don't put up with that bro
I better use the right problem but you
but sir you have an Adam apple and a
beard you're really exactly the same
dude you just have a dress on a little
effort
has to but no not so that it's really
more of a walking [__] you for a lot of
people I think pronouns for a lot of
people now are like yeah they're like
you know what I'm gonna be different and
I'm gonna Stick it to the Man so I'm
just gonna bug people I get it it is
weird dude I was watching uh it popped
up on Twitter I sent to our group chat
with you me Rogan Eddie where uh Austin
has a serial killer they think where uh
had on a swivel Joe yeah I said I put
head on swivel Joe Austin and all
rainbows and [__] cowboy boots and
because they have a serial killer there
so I I read a little bit of it and then
you know sent to the group and I post
about it so you know like Austin come in
hot with the serial killer and then
people were sending me things have you
heard the smiley face Killers it's a
group of serial killers what this gets
deep dude hold on dude strap on your
freaking vest here this gets this runs
deep so what's happening is young men
well I guess like college age early 30s
are going missing and they're found in
that they're finding where they drowned
in the river but there's no sign of like
there's no they can't they're just like
oh they're probably drunk fell on the
river when you look at the amount of
people that have ended up dead in the
river and yeah like forensic people like
no that's too much of coincidence all
these young men are dying the river so
then and I sent gin this then this guy
who's investigating it he's working with
the FBI zoomed out it's not just having
Austin it's in Boston to Minneapolis
it's in a ton of areas where all these
young men at leave bars end up drowning
in the river they think it's this group
called the smiley face Killers it's a
group of serial killers a group yeah
dude scary [__] I don't know you mean
they're talking to each other online I
don't know no not online no no no no no
no no killing dudes yeah only men only
men leaving bars gay stuff uh they they
don't know but the reason they call it
the smiley face Killers is around where
they find the bodies they're fine smiley
faces if they're getting roofied it's no
no no no no no no hey your gay narrative
on it okay no you got a problem dude
because you're gay if you murder no
there's no roofies
yeah you said it to me I don't know you
I'm gonna go no I'm okay yeah you wish
Playboy there's no gay narrative here
dude are you in Hollywood no there's no
gay narrative as much as you want this
to be a gay thing it's not these guys
are no roofies nothing oh they're pants
down nope fully clothed no weiner play
no foul play with the wiener are there
is there did I send you the one thing
the guy sent me he sent me two different
things you go to the video the video is
where the guy breaks it down it's on
tick tock
watch this dude this is on Tick Tock
okay get ready
hold on one second he's not but he
doesn't talk he's doing sign language
for a reason right oh
but get ready
so I'll just
go in Minneapolis in Wisconsin and north
of Ohio in Pittsburgh and of course you
have the smiley visitors in Boston I
made a map of the data that I have for
Chicago black is where bodies have been
found in blue is where people have been
missing and orange is where people were
attempting to be picked up I also have
made one for Austin where blue is where
people are missing from it's all
concentrated truly on the same street
and black is where they are found
you can see I have all of the heat out
over here there is so much this is a
nationwide problem and these maps that
I've made are accessible through my
beacons but the method of operating for
all these missing people is exactly the
same for the most part it is guys
leaving bars drunk alone by themselves
at night bar club party whatever
and then they'd never make it home I
don't know what's going on thank you for
everyone for taking me the next video
I'm working with him already I'm in the
serial killer group in Austin and
continuing to add more information as I
get it I'm working with Mark in Boston
and we are continuing to add more
information as we get it but I will
continue to push this story you're
really going to tell me that all these
people are just falling in there's no
issues for months and then all of a
sudden there's four people who fall into
a river or a lake in three weeks I spoke
with the producer NBC last night I am
working with Dee from under the desk
news and she will be running the story
as well
I have not just theories anymore I have
evidence I know what's going on and it's
so big and it's so deep and it's really
wild at least for Chicago I know what's
happening Nationwide all I know is that
we have a major public safety crisis and
nobody goes on by themselves nobody's
walking home taking an Uber make sure
your friends get there I have to keep
some of these cards close to my chest
until I can get the FBI involved because
accomplish is not cutting it anymore
they might be involved please please
stay safe if you have any information
give it to me here message me on
Instagram cops might be involved that's
why a lot of people think
now I wouldn't believe him if he wasn't
wearing glasses
classes are always to me that's too much
of a convenience where just all these
guys leaving the bar same time end up
drowning in rivers nearby these major
Metropolitan yeah my problem is this do
we have evidence of bludgeoning or
anything like that are they just drowned
because you gotta I gotta ask you how do
you drown a grown man I read somewhere
said no trauma but yeah they're not
finding anything yeah so you know I got
you think it's just guys fall in the
river in all the cities I'll tell you
why it's never happened before B at this
rate you know why Austin yeah I think no
they're not finding that in there
there's a lot of drugs nobody see you're
wrong I'd be really drunk but I'll put
all of them in every city so so there is
a market increase in drinking Across the
Nation especially in cities I don't know
why but that is the case sure me too but
um that's interesting right so maybe
people get are getting just drunker and
maybe this has always happened no it
hasn't well no I'm telling you the stats
prove it I went deep in this you want
this to be a cereal no no but I'm I'm in
the middle I'm with you with a little
bit it's like but they can't find any
Foul Play but then the thing that's
alarming is how many people in all these
metropolitan cities are drowning like
this and the smiley faces what is this
smiley face what is that they think
that's the signature of the serial
killer so where is the smiley face
around all the where the bodies are
being found they find a smiley face
begin the mid 1990s getting a smiley
face Killers has been proposed as the
source of numerous deaths of young men
found in the midwest in those cases
young fit men were found dead in bodies
of water if they had been out drinking
so they find the smiley face now they
asked a forensic person they go I mean
smiley face is pretty Universal it just
happens that it's in all these years
not in the body's around like where
they're fighting the bodies like it's
like their signature there's too many
coincidence for me you know yeah
I like it it's definitely interesting I
question your your police work sir and
uh I just do you think it's all
coincidence I think that there are
people on Tick Tock who have a lot of
time in their hands and are excited
about this well no smiley face murdered
police the police are pretty good at
seeing what being able to tell the
difference between a drowning and Trauma
these these guys have been you know
these Detectives
if the taxes Caron said there's
something going on would be different
but since they've not said that I don't
know if there's pressure
but the police are not involved I don't
think the police are killing people in
this I don't know
you know I don't know why the police I
don't know who the police what do you
mean by the police the department a
rogue cop was a serial killer you know
maybe yeah
but then how did he get him in the water
right
did he did he bang him and then he keep
going to the gay thing dude that's
that's alarming there's a lot of bangers
if there's a therapist right now she'd
be like oh your friend's gay but if
you're down okay wait it was just fine
oh God so watch this if I'm drunk
and I'm coming out and you bought me a
drink and you roofied me you're gonna
say you want to go down to the river and
I'm gonna go uh hey buddy here's a trump
to your weird theory of gayness there's
no drugs in their system
well they might have been watered out no
if you can detect all that
water down you're the worst detective
ever you know what you do it's about
information when you get water all the
drugs get seeped out into the river
you'd be the worst detective ever right
you see a shooting like see it time and
time again another black guy like how do
you did they even know we're in
Brentwood did I inspect his anus
just a question I know it is interesting
though huh it is and all those all those
cities it very well could be a serial
killer but typically when they find
victims of Serial killing there's
there's they were killed somehow you
know well yeah all these guys were
killed somehow dumbass yeah but no you
see a mark right like a bullet a knife a
strangulation you could be obsessed with
water
there's all sorts of different serial
killers how would he how would he you
got to take him down the river and drown
him that's hard you ever tried to drown
somebody that's uh they're drunk imagine
pretty easy well for you here you're a
giant if it's a group of guys pretty
easy I remember that's where the theory
a group of guys they're like let's drown
this guy yeah because there's no
evidence they're a gang that's I mean
that's what the theories
killing people dude would the BTK killer
get out of it what Richard Ramirez or
Ted Bundy just don't feel like there are
that many
what do you guys think who's right here
if I'm for detectives I know Nick Davis
in his hometown of Wisconsin he thought
he got attacked by the smiley face
killer but he just passed out in a snow
bed drunk
yeah okay but all right so we're good so
far that's my detective work that's good
with Detective work so far he had a
drunk friend who passed out in snow and
thought it was the BTK killer this has
n't changed and they were by bars it was
all the same things by bars so I guess
like yeah I mean but I mean the amount
at the a certain amount the amount and
the timing the amount here's where it
gets alarming where you should you where
you can't just ride it off as like ah
it's a bunch of drunk guys fall into the
river the amount of men that are dying
in every city no it's foreign just
Austin Boston Boston Minneapolis not
that much
in three months
a dudes fall on the river put a fence up
put a fence up look at me yeah no yeah
many as eight in the past 10 months
that's a tonby of dead bodies end up in
the river yeah maybe maybe they just
it's alarming I wonder if they died
somewhere else no evidence of Foul Play
but maybe look like that's climbed to
four
experts on the outside say so many
drownings in one place would be a
striking coincidence
you know they're definitely serial
killers in Texas I'm sure so so this is
a retired NYPD detective uh uh said just
from the shared number and the fact that
there's so many in a short period of
time I don't believe that's an
accidental and I give it that's the guy
that investigated the scene like
graffiti of SM the smiley face yeah
graffiti near the deaths yes so I don't
know man I don't know was there foliage
growing in the area something to think
about though it's a little too because
they're thinking about calling them the
foliage killer as well and or the lake
killer because they were found in lakes
yeah I don't know if it's a river
you know fast running River you can die
release but a lake I'd be like even if
you're drunk you're like okay all the
time but I mean I would fall into the
lake and then walk out if you're on the
bank unless it's like a huge yeah you
pass out who the [__] knows I don't know
a little too convenient for me maybe it
is maybe it is interesting at least
you're safe because only killing young
men
right are you just I'm not serious you
could just wander around the streets and
awesome like nope smiley face no one is
interested I'd be like am I like how old
are you all 64 little no yeah he's kind
of yeah he already lived his life come
on man I'm by myself though it might
even be like this I mean I'd be like oh
no more hustling
yeah that is strange
it's just interesting fun stuff to dive
into it is it is very interesting I
don't know
at least it's only in the Midwest
I wonder if they got
yeah it could have been maybe he poisons
them hey dumbass how many times I gotta
tell you there's none of that in their
system there's no gay stuff work going
on so he might be there's no point it
might be a very strong swimmer
like Leah Thomas
grabs him brings him under the wall now
you're thinking right Thomas my I'm just
saying she's very interesting she has
anger towards men very interesting that
a fully intact male will call a female
who robbed a bunch of women of their
All-American status and their
scholarships okay
um grabs and it cuts them down it could
be that was a whole long that's the long
evil merman an evil merman who shows up
he's like I want to buy the mermaid
serial killer now you're cooking with
gas yeah
yeah I'm Leah Thomas I'm the best
swimmer College swimmer female college
swimmer
yeah maybe
interesting yep when I come down to the
river and see my dong oh prove it right
go for a swim [__] they die struggle
struggle struggle so I like this side of
you dude you don't have zombie on to it
all right did you watch the Ryan Garcia
fight I did watch the Ryan Garcia fight
and uh
uh tank Davis Ryan Garcia is a great
boxer sometimes though you you're
fighting a once in a generation boxer
and I think tank is that good yeah
they're both good I think uh well Ryan
Garcia got over zealous got when he
started having some success kind of you
know out got out front of his skis and
got caught in that second round and he
was like oh [__] it's like yeah that's
not snowflake that's not snowflakes like
no dude that's Saint Davis yeah I just
think tank Davis is a different level of
boxes he's been in the higher profile
box but he's been there before for Ryan
that's his first major fight here's the
thing it's all good of course a losses
in you know a death like I said Ryan
Garcia is a great boxer but you're
talking about you're talking about the
best right now Facebook might be the
next I don't know I don't see anybody
beating him in that weight class he hits
so hard and he's so good he's so good
yeah but this wasn't for any belt so now
for tank there's some Stevenson's out
there Haney's out there who's fighting
lomachenko I think Haney's probably the
most technical box that he can fight so
we'll see but from here on out you know
I mean Lomo is older now but Lomo would
be it'd be a really interesting fight
they won't do that back in the day did
he fight tfomo who uh attention no so
there are people out there for him
there are definitely people out there
for him but um
Haney and uh Stevenson would be the ones
though
I would never I will never uh Shakur
Stevenson yeah I would never bet against
attack at this point I I think he hits
unnaturally hard at that I think he's
just I think he's the best
sometimes so people are just better than
everybody else
would you say that's fair yeah but yeah
you said a little more experience
watching those big time fights and then
also
um
just got that X Factor though right I
mean yes and no he was a three to one
favorite bro so it's not like you beat
the world here right he's a three to one
favor for a reason and also Ryan Garza
uh yeah Ryan Garcia you know he had to
deplete himself he couldn't rehydrate so
you're dealing with that as well he's a
much bigger fighter so you're dealing
with that as well came into the fight
with an injury not taking anything away
from tank it just is what it is guys
fight with injuries uh rib injury and
that's when he got hit to the rib that's
why to answer the Bell is that what it
was so you know those morons that go oh
come on he couldn't get up from that
it's like okay first you've never been
hit there you get tapped there you don't
matter but the problem is is people say
that like oh Brian's not tough it's like
first of all that's when I knew he was
injured I didn't talk to his camp out I
didn't need to I've been hitting the
body like that and usually you know it's
gonna suck for a few minutes then it
goes away you can continue to fight you
can answer the bell for Ryan with his
experience to just take the knee it's
like oh he's really injured he came in
the fight injured yeah he was injured to
the body got hit in the exact spot it's
an injury and he's like this ain't worth
it I'm out the other day yeah cause he
took a knee but yeah well well that's
body shots always delayed it's not
instant but that was always longer delay
than ever not really no it was it was it
was a much longer delay than I've ever
seen it just was sure yeah okay it was
it was a longer delay body shots are
always delayed I know that body shards
aren't that delayed what happened was he
got hit you saw him cover you saw him
covers and it was so bad he took it and
he was like I think some like it's
probably the same injury and he goes
[__] this this is not worth it I'm
taking any that's what happened it was
like I can't continue I'm not gonna be
able to move my body because he was he
was like this would be your argument is
the body shot isn't usually that delayed
the there was a delayed Grimace on his
face then took a knee but what I'm
saying is that so it wasn't that delayed
when you get caught there's a there's
like almost always like a predictable
delay which is probably one one thousand
two a thousand usually yeah this was
longer so I think it wasn't because the
Grimace on his face was what and then it
was so bad he went to it what I'm saying
is that I think it was so bad that he
might have gone oh this is like my body
shot maybe whether but I was already
injured and this ain't [__] this I'm I'm
I can't do it like that's what I'm
saying like anyone with his caliber in
his pedigree would answer that call and
be like all right I'll move around for a
little bit and learn to live you know
move around but he just couldn't if
anybody's ever boxed even a little bit
if you've ever gotten hit there like uh
I was with somebody who said ah that
that fight was fixed I go dude you like
watch it in slow motion if you get hit
like I don't know for me anyway just
getting hit like Bop touched like that
you full like a lot of times yeah it's
so great like I wouldn't be my circle of
friends if he said that well but if you
don't if you've never been hit there you
don't know that's Ryan Garcia he's a
professional box if you've never been
hit there people go ah boxing's fixed no
hold on hold on you got it you gotta be
hit there I mean and especially when
tank gets here and no anyone that would
even take but it's also like and if you
come in with an injury that must have
been awful awful I didn't know he was
injured though because it makes sense
why he stayed on this people were so
upset I said that I go not taking
anything away from tank you did great
that second round knockout was
ridiculous when Ryan Garcia got back up
he got back up there doing the seventh
with the body shot but at Ryan Garcia's
level did not answer the Bell on that or
the the standing count see he was Andrew
going to the fight be like oh you take
how can you call it how do you know I'm
like all right okay
and then his training partner came out
goes yeah I'm the one that injured him
before the fight he was injured going
into that fight there you go
weird sounds like you know what I'm
talking about yeah yeah
yeah that I mean again it's not taking
anything away from I I again I watched
Ryan Garcia as good as he is the fight
wasn't going his way like he was still
down the car I gave him and this is
being super biased maybe three rounds
going that seventh probably two on most
accounts probably two rounds going that
seventh round and tank gets batters
rounds going on and downloads your data
so it wasn't going his Direction anyway
my only caveat to that is if he didn't
have the injury you would have got more
rounds he probably still would have been
in a lot of trouble I'm not saying if
you didn't have the injury would have
won the fight I'm just saying that's the
reason why he didn't answer it's not a
thing that was fixed or that he's you
know some [__] there's nothing no no
get the same as injured people who say
that are drive me nuts drive me nuts did
you not see him get back up after taking
that overhand left did you not see him
get straight back up I mean he's a tall
shot kid he's tough he's a fighter bro
yeah through and through and he didn't
get himself there and competitive by
being but also one of the reasons the
only reason that fight happens because
Ryan Garcia and his team put up with all
the demands like get what it takes to
get this fight done amazing yeah that's
a Fighter's fighter that's what boxer
needs yeah if Fury would do this or
Deontay Wilder all the usick all these
uh Earl Spence and Crawford if they had
more of a mindset like running Garcia
that's Crawford I thought that was
happening so what's happened in the past
three years Brian yeah what's going on
contracts camps falls through
they even had a date on the books and
then they backed up no that's what's
wrong with boxing that's why UFC
surpassed it years ago
divisions aren't talking to each other
all kinds of stuff it's not even
divisions it's Camp no I mean promotion
promotions yeah different promotions
don't talk to each other so you don't
get the best the best of what time you
do they're both older they're not in
their Prime that's what's wrong with it
that's why hats off the javonta Davis
and Ryan Garcia they started online they
called each other out and told their
Camp no we got to make this fight happen
yeah you're not but it's not for belts
we don't care it's the fight people want
to see it made it happen that's boxing
100 it's great 100 great yep loved it
reaction
all right
actually let's start with this let me
just uh pull it up tell us whatever to
do dude
Morgan Whalen cancel Morgan Wallen
cancel this show oh before we even talk
about this how about Tucker Carlson and
Don Lemon both fired today I'm glad you
brought this up
glad you brought this up keto George
just found that out your take sir Don
Lemon a long time coming I can't believe
you lasted this long because
[__] yeah no ratings Tucker Carlson
ratings biggest thing on Fox by far not
even close I think 10 million viewership
like his show just his his single it is
bring it up 10 million his show was
bigger than all the network of CNS so
yeah and I'm not a huge Tucker Carlson
whatever right they're both you know
mainstream media so can I give you tiger
Carlton part of the thing was is it
shows you how big big Pharma is and how
much influence the heck is he was very
weary on pushing the vaccines and that
stuff and that's what paid the majority
of the bills that go into Fox so it's
coming out that he was kind of anti-big
Pharma and then you know he got fired
well I have a different take on why do
you think some other shit's coming out
yeah so here's my take on Tucker I think
what happened was he does eat when they
went into Discovery with dominion and
those uh it turns out that what he was
saying on air was very different than
what he was texting about Trump I can't
stand him he's a demon he's Satan
whatever he's talking about he's and
that was already an issue where his
older viewers of fox
tend to go hold on hold on what and then
Maria Bartholomew or whatever her name
is bartoloma and Sean Hannity it seems
that they were begging the Trump
campaign for more evidence on on on
Election audience and Alexa and they
couldn't come up with it yeah and they
kind of knew that which is why obviously
they settled because they did not want
Laura Ingram Tucker Carlson Sean Hannity
uh and and all their all their stars to
be dragged up because they would have
been dragged up before every in court it
would have been very embarrassing
because they couldn't have backed it up
so they were like cutter losses now 786
million dollars I think is half of the
net profits they make in a year that's a
significant chunk okay but here's why I
think they fired Tucker Carlson
there's another
there's another lawsuit blooming
everybody from another voting machine
company okay
and uh they're going to go into
Discovery and I believe and add a bunch
of stuff more stuff yeah that Tucker
Carlson said that was inconsistent and
they got to let them go it's like they
were like look
I think you're playing with fire too
because if Tucker Carlson now I'm sure
he has the NDA which I'm sure you
wouldn't mind violating if someone would
pay the fees the fines for it but I'm
sure he has a lot of information about
big Pharma what was going on behind the
scenes there and he with his fan base
massive massive yeah Don Lemon I don't
know what the [__] he's gonna do did
Tucker Carlson's beat massive man yes on
his own platform he's gonna be massive
he's allowed to talk freely about what
was going on behind the scenes and stuff
he's also he's also the direct
connection to Trump you know that yep
the Hannity in trouble close but Tucker
I bet the the NDA yeah and I don't know
if he's gonna has the same access to
Trump now that Trump saw what he said
so like that's that's pretty I don't
know if that bothers Trump maybe not
yeah if you have a big platform he's
like yeah cool people talk [__] non-stop
maybe he talk [__] I don't know yeah
maybe
um all I know is Fox NC in her big
trouble
Fox when you looked at the ratings
outside Tucker screwed CNN's been
screwed well I said this might be the
the thing that the downfall of fox
Rupert Murdoch remember he had to shut
down a profitable what was it called the
sun they were they were they were
hacking into people's phones in the UK
it was a major Scandal hacking into
people's phones and then somebody killed
himself as a result and he was brought
up and said this is the most humiliating
and humbling moment of my life he said
but Rupert Murdoch is you know Siri you
will I mean this guy's yeah shark and he
had to shut that he fired people and
then ultimately I think he shot it down
yeah Fox is that's a big payday but now
they've got another lawsuit billion
dollars a year this is another lawsuit
off advertising but with the numbers you
know those advertisers only keep up for
so long I don't know what they're gonna
do CNN either because they've lost the
trust of everyone now there's the far
left far right that you know far left
watch CNN far right watches Fox for the
most part and then you know some America
watches it and get their ideas from that
but in general like there's no trust in
either of those Outlets well you saw
what happened with CNN here's the thing
well in both of them but even though
Tucker Carlson has a huge fan base
there's a huge opportunity for someone
to come along on network TV and you're
not left you're not right you just give
us the truth there's such an opportunity
for somebody I don't know who that is
there's somebody out there because they
can get the back end of a Murdoch or
these billionaires or Elon musum to give
us the straight news like you know
breaking points they should be on fire
my question to you though is would uh
would that get as big an audience
without having bias yes yeah yeah I
think so I think so because most of us
aren't far left far right now most was
in the middle that's what the truth
that's all people want I like what you
mean we know for a fact like there's fat
checking they don't report anything
there's no agenda they're not backed by
big Pharma there's such that's why
breaking points is massive that's Sagar
and uh yeah they're massive on on a
podcast massive yeah massive because
they they they go the ones on left ones
on the right and they call it how they
see it I love there's no fake news there
but there's an opportunity for someone
now if I'm Tucker Carlson I call up Don
Lemon go hey I know we've had our
differences
we're gonna do a show together like
First Take
that's interesting
you do a first take like Stephen A and
Skip Bayless much for politics that's
really think about I think how big
that'd be now here's the we can't shout
over each other we can both make a point
then we move on we got to move on
and you have a you have a producer you
know yeah you know what I think
I really believe this I think uh Don
Lemon is a lot more conservative than
people think
that's one of the reasons he got in
trouble yeah I think Don Lemon it
started to come out too on you I think
Don Lemon is so sick
like come on nobody's watching that and
I was like hey hey don't shoot the
messenger yeah he's like what do you
want me to do like this it's a market
Don Lemon if you start talking to him
about like for example is it racism or
is it culture when it comes to the black
community look at what he said in the
back before he became a star yeah Don
Lemon you might find has a lot of
conservative talking points that he
couldn't get to well all these people on
the on these Chris Cuomo was Santa Chris
Chrome was saying man there's so many
things I have to say Christianity show
now and he's not that crazy
he's a guy Chris is a dude I know Chris
yeah now there's and I have friends at
home very now there's not you know he
doesn't have to you know push whatever
agenda they want to push so now you hear
him talk he's like oh you're not crazy
he's a dude most these guys are normal
people but yeah it's no different than
they're like hold up the Undertaker
doesn't believe in the afterlife and
look he's not into ghosts got himself in
a situation and he was on the fence for
taking that job a long time ago I'm
friends with somebody who talked him
into it but when he took the job it
wasn't like that right but they gave
there was so much money involved and you
got you the pressure to toe that's that
specific line is so powerful but I think
a lot of it he hated it I think you're
going to see Don Lemon come out and be
far more moderate he's going to be the
old voice of reason people don't either
he won't be far left no no I bet he's
just a normal dude he's gonna call him
he's gonna call it like it is yeah
so that's why you tell me you want to
watch him and Tucker Carlson 100 major
Network TV one well no I'd watch that
dude if I'm the Box you're missing it if
I'm seeing anything I've watched him on
the internet I would they should have
their own show on YouTube and make all
the money oh Elon Musk or Ben Shapiro or
your boy
um Crowder should offer him some sort of
percentage of the company you two are
gonna do a show you get all the money
from it it's gonna be on whatever
patreon you guys can have all the money
you know how much money those two would
think they would crush but but you gotta
put the ego to the side we can't have
you guys shouting over each other
Tucker's gonna go you're gonna go yeah
you never know they're Pros they've been
doing it so long they're aware of how
the listener watches something yeah and
it'd be ridiculous okay you guys want to
make money
anybody want to work with us that'd be
like the biggest thing now this this is
something to note too Tucker Carlson's
head producer who's the Mastermind
behind was the riot and everything great
writer walked out too he quit today too
to go with Tucker so it's not like
Tucker's gonna smart go away to Montana
and sit in the corner with his kids I
don't know he's going somewhere
he's a behemoth yeah I'm gonna tell you
right now fanbase isn't loyal's TV is
going to open up they're gonna they're
gonna back a Brinks truck into the
biggest Vault they can find for him uh
daily wires
Rumble will do whatever I bet you right
now Tucker goes to rumble I I wouldn't
be surprised I wouldn't be surprised I
wouldn't be surprised because it's
crowded on Rumble Crowders on Rumble
yeah Andrew dates on Rumble now you have
Tucker and his fan base but here's the
rumble will take over yeah but and
that's what they need someone like him
but I think in order to so it's not such
a far right thing which they don't want
they just happening speech Yes free
speech so if you have Don Lemon on there
and Tucker great idea then you get both
the fan bases great idea I guarantee I
guarantee there are a lot of people
opening up there you know they're just
like hey come come I would watch even if
I don't agree with them just for the
sheer entertainment value yeah
apparently though there's some rumor and
some chatter about CNN did try to tell
uh Don Lemon and he said he got fired oh
so don Lem yeah this is interesting it's
funny CNN's calling fake news now right
because they're the notorious would be
like fake news dude we don't believe in
that I think they're the first ones to
coin the phrase it's funny right so don
or conspiracy everyone's conspiracy
theories so Don Lemon goes after 17
years at CNN I can't believe they'd have
the audacity to have a you know a decent
yeah to call me or you'll let me know
they did it via text and see how like
that's actually fake news we tried to
concept a meeting to tell you in person
you decide to go to Twitter
can we see that is there can I see that
yeah I'm not making it up I was informed
this morning uh by my age and I've been
terminated by CNN I'm stunned
um after 17 years at CNN I would have
thought someone in the management would
have the decency to tell me directly at
no time was I ever given any indication
that I would not be able to continue to
do the work I've Loved At the network
it's clear there are some larger issues
at play that said thanks to everybody
and then CNN came out was like uh not so
much dude we actually reached out to you
CNN and Don Lemon are part of ways down
before don't leave a statement about
this morning
hold on it says Don lemon's statement
about this morning's events is
inaccurate uh he was offered an
opportunity to meet with management but
instead released a statement on Twitter
boom
yeah that's what that's only caveat with
Don Lemon he is a diva tendency there's
a lot of sure now now uh uh Cooper is
going to be their guy now Cooper you'll
see AC Cooper starting to take over now
well I think that CNN is going to I
think will they have a new management
like I was like we're not going to be
doing what we've been doing yeah he's
like we got to tell the news you got to
tell the truth you gotta you can't be
this biased yeah
yeah it's interesting
it's crazy the same day though both the
the faces of networks out
yeah
all right chin now let's get into it
rumble's just backing up beep beep beep
I don't know what you have to offer
Tucker
um I lost my voice y'all cancel like the
minutes before the concert it's actually
after their their beginning you know
their opener came on and when like
that's how close to when he was gonna
perform that he had to cancel and they
put it on like the big screen here uh
ladies and gentlemen unfortunately
Morgan has lost his voice since then
able to perform tonight there's
therefore Tonight Show has been canceled
please make your way save sustain
refunds for tonight's event will be
available at point of purchase yeah and
he apologized on his Instagram what you
know before that though he said he tried
everything with his doctors and
everything else but he just couldn't do
it they're probably core Zone shots
everything
lose my voice so I spent the day resting
up talking to my doctor working through
my vocal exercise trying to get better
but he thought I'd be able to take the
stage and it kills me to deliver this so
close to show time but my voice is shot
I'm able to sing all tickets will be fun
at point of purchase so sorry
yeah I believe him it's not like you
know why wouldn't he want to perform why
would you want to let down you lose your
voice sometimes I will say this though
just because this is you know we have to
like be honest about all this stuff so
there are rumors from people filming
stuff that he was like maybe potentially
too drunk the security guard said he was
too drunk to perform he felt I'm not
saying that's the truth I'm just saying
that that's what the rumors are not a
pro not a pro like that no no but he's
been doing so many shows with our you
know the friends you know like yeah yeah
artists and all them like yeah he's he's
a definite Pro yeah yeah jelly roll yeah
homie too see him and Theodore boys
yeah you lose your voice sometimes I
mean such a huge show yeah dude if you
perform enough you're gonna lose your
voice at some point if you don't like
there are a lot of singers that's
happened before yeah I've heard people
talking about getting cortisone shots in
their [__] throat oh yeah what
whatever it takes whatever it takes
all right I'm just gonna cancel this
show
this is uh from
a week ago I believe this isn't a Target
and this woman she had she had bought
like over a thousand dollars worth of
stuff at Target a lot of [__] at Target
yeah and then she couldn't afford the
rest of it I guess you know she had a
certain amount of money but then she's
like you I deserve the rest of them
through reparations oh she's crazy she's
kind of crazy she's definitely crazy she
knew she didn't have the money but still
and she wanted to have this talk so she
asked for the manager anyone involved
and I'll just show you the video real
quick so the first person that was
called was a woman and you could see her
oh so the woman's not a small the
woman's like whoa yeah so she's going
straight to the woman like
yeah and now the guy goes I got time
today
so she keeps coming forward and look and
she's very like you know intimidating
and she is very big she's super big
and then so there's a loss prevention
officer officer that came through
afterwards oh it was the security guard
but then she starts following him
why are they all white
what Target is this I mean I'm just
saying so she's following this loss
prevention officer to his office and
he's like he's backing up and then he
had to punch her in the stage
so she kept following him she kept
following him and he felt threatened and
after it's good like I saw the entire
video the woman is pretty does she does
she pop up after that punch no I don't
think she popped up right after but the
cops saying that yeah the cops came
they're like you're in the wrong you're
the one that's intimidating these people
and then the guy was like Hey back off
and you kept chasing him and then he was
like backed in a corner yeah so he had
to protect himself even though it's a
woman no no she has a knife deals that
thing oh it's a good shot I mean that is
Trevor Wallace and she said this was her
Rosa Parks moment oh wow wow yeah so
she's not not the mask she's not all
there yeah okay well that's what you get
sometimes and did the guy get in trouble
at all no the guy was good oh that's
cool for the reparations plan in San
Francisco's incredible
it's amazing that's gonna pass
ion this is uh George you can handle
this one
um this young lady had a tragic death in
her family oh the fish died it looks
like a goldfish yeah
it's hard man
we had a funeral for her fish
oh
[Music]
my brothers are laughing yeah
she's just the one the one with the
Hood's not having it
my fish hey man hey man
[Music]
the brothers all try not to laugh
R.I.P fish yeah kids take it hard man
sometimes the fish happen they have new
tank syndrome where they you know they
get in the tank and then they die Tiger
has he draws whenever they dies walls
full of like tennis it's called NTS new
tech syndrome yeah it sucks it's called
what it's new tank syndrome when you
take a fish and put them in a new tank
yeah that's why when you get the bad guy
leaving there for 30 minutes to get used
to the temperature and whatever even
that sometimes but they have uh formula
now called new tank syndrome it fights
that like I actually got five five fish
yesterday you put that new tank there I
haven't had one dying forever now really
yeah they have a formula they use from
seitrums called uh through the new tanks
in them yeah you put it in and help them
great story
anyway there's this thing with the tanks
you got to put it in there and they
don't die because they don't suffer from
new tanks they could help her they could
help these that little girl out though
if the mom had that you know what do you
have against them see Jim sells it let
me know what he's talking about that
yeah he tells us about countries again
dude cutting trees tell us about hey
tell us how green Portland is no they
don't act like my stories aren't way
more awesome terrible conditioning the
[__] tank story for your terrible
fish that I don't care about and you
better talk about catching two fish I'll
eat all your dumb fish tell us about
catching two fishes you're over after
the first fish eight and a half feet
long dude and I'm sore CrossFit sore
you're [__] dumb but you don't have
any video I'll catching no videos
but for us for the show all right I
don't know [__] videos
shut up keep going [__] this spot
so there's this charity game with
firefighters from New York and uh NYPD
as well right oh New York firefighters
and New York cops
they do a boxing tournament too and it
might be more Universe
yeah they get into it oh yeah some tough
dudes apparently the fire department
they on this uh you know this hockey
game they destroyed the cops so I'll
show you some of the highlights here
holy [__] this is like a big thing it's
really big
no do they just drop the gloves and yeah
so that's a fire department guy versus a
New York NYPD guy
and this is for charity that's why it's
funny
and the fire department has the
mustaches on oh damn oh he's whooping
his ass oh
yeah once you get dropped in hockey they
stop it yep look at them
oh I love this guy
[Applause]
so that was one of them here's another
one here oh multiple fights multiple it
was a lot of fights
[Music]
[Applause]
firemen win uh oh
foreign
[Applause]
kind of whoop their ass
great man firemen I'll have mustaches
awesome yeah I'm a legit hockey huh
legit
have you guys seen this video yet no
it's a little older it's from March
2017. just let me just play it for you
this is actually really cool
[Music]
Menace this little kid
it's cute
it's everything
[Applause]
look over right
he just tries to eat
he's trying to eat everything I love him
literally
[Music]
I love that kid eat the brown sugar
he's quick too I know the mom's all
laughing and put it in I think that's a
grandma so much
oh
I want so this kid's a menace
his face
ah good boy
that's so funny I said Kate is a mess
that kid's amazing I love it this is
also from not that long I mean it's not
that recent but this is a dog
that is with his owner and he copies his
owner as owners doing squats
legitimately so smart though damn
so smart
I'd say smart it's pretty cool
athletic animal it's just trippy why is
Brian rock hard right now all he kept on
a smart animal oh so smart oh my God
look at the muscles such a smart animal
I
God
I guess this is the last one this
cross-dressing thieves cross-dressing
thieves that is a great um that's a
great name for a band that I want to
start uh that's a good one you know that
lgbtq the Democrats are trying to get a
bill passed that you over the Border if
you're lgbtq you can just walk I'm out
and why when Isis or just what kind of
gaydar do they would have if I'm a
cartel member I'm like hey amigo just
put a dress on it it's gonna be I would
say that it's gonna be lines of Mexican
dudes in wigs yeah I would I'd be like
I'm trans I never win it'll be like
it'll be like Portland no effort no
effort
what's this one suspect arrested yeah so
these two
that look like two what what they're
dudes no they're actually dressing as
women yeah so they came into this mall
and stole a bunch of different perfumes
in California these are dudes these are
actual dudes in Broward
so I mean but check out this one in the
white top like with like booty shorts on
sure
that's a criminal with a rump and a nice
wig yes so then uh loss prevention they
did tackle them they tried their best
attack on here and get them but they
couldn't get them all said you'll see
him wait that guy's tackling them good
luck there's two people yeah so that
they try to get him eventually they
found out the description of their
getaway car which was driven by a girl
oh yeah so these guys the guys pepper
sprayed the Lost prevention people
they got away but they arrested the the
driver and one of the suspects and this
is the driver it's a female oh she's a
girl but it's just interesting why would
you dress up as a girl to seal perfect
because well well
my guess is they're not high they're not
they're not sophisticated criminals yeah
right oh this is in Florida did they
specifically Drive they were like let's
go get a bunch of stuff
what's up did they specifically dress
and drag to steal that's the thing that
they did which I'm like I get it because
I guess you might want to just you know
but wouldn't that draw more attention
because it looks like booties they look
like tall dudes I wonder if his friends
like damn Dwayne a mask shut up dude
we're doing it for the job good job
let's go put the wig on it shut up yeah
are they more lenient towards
transgender criminals I don't know uh
not in Florida no idea what happened
yeah Florida
is fighting Disney yeah Santa's going
against Disney nobody's ever won right
now
it's tough and that's pretty much it
another another episode we did it man we
did it buddy we did it we got our house
of macadamia I mean I've been chomping
on my house in macadamia nuts which are
delicious chocolate you're coming up uh
Port uh Charlotte you're gonna miss the
companion with Ryan Garcia poor
Charlotte I will miss that companion Leo
Muhammad I want to meet him Muhammad and
Gilbert Burns Bilal and Gilbert I'm
missing that we just did a shop
I love that guy yeah how great is he
he's the best
um poor Charlotte I will be there May
5th 6th not the fourth I gotta do crowd
of the fourth
um and then Stress Factory in New
Brunswick New Jersey Friday May 12th
Saturday May 13th I'll see you there I
know it says May 11th I have to change
that
uh uh May I'll be around La doing spots
we have fight campaigning Cowboys fight
companion May 6 with Ryan Garcia and two
monsters I'll announce those soon uh
comedy tour dates uh La Jolla Comedy
Store June 2nd through the 4th the
fourth is a Sunday that's Sunday at 7
p.m but uh Friday two shows Saturday two
shows one show Sunday belt then I'm over
across the pond starts with Belfast
these are a theater run one show only
Belfast June 15th Glasgow June 17th
Manchester June 18th London June 22nd
Cardiff June 23rd then I end the trip uh
over there in Ireland Dublin is June
25th all right get to take you to
thinkboy.com that's it kids that's it
love you guys see ya
peace